The Golden Globes is a party, and nearly every
celebrity in Hollywood is invited. But it seems
a certain contagious disease made its way
onto the guest list as well. Keep watching
to find out who won’t be attending any events
for a while, and instead will be back at home.
It seems that this year's award season is
not going quite as planned. On January 10th,
2023, the 80th Golden Globe Awards took
place to celebrate the best of film and
television from the previous year. After
last year's less-than-stellar show that
saw the Golden Globes go for a hybrid style
of part Zoom and part in-person presentation,
this year's event brought things back to a more
traditional and welcome manner. The prestigious
ceremony saw some pretty major events take place,
from Ke Huy Quan's wholesome best supporting actor
win for "Everything Everywhere All At Once"
to Eddie Murphy's Cecil B. DeMille Award win
and subsequent speech that referenced
another notable award ceremony moment.
But as with every year, the Globes couldn't
escape from having some less-than-pleasing
moments bog down the festivities. This
year's show brought the ceremony to its
lowest ratings yet and continues to see
controversy from within the industry,
most notably with "The Whale" star Brendan Fraser
skipping out on the event as an act of protest,
Entertainment Weekly reported. To top it
all off, it seems that several of those
who were in attendance took home something
far less desirable than a golden statue.
Following this year's Golden Globes ceremony,
an uptick in COVID-19 cases has been spreading
among some of the night's attendees. First to
report being infected was Jamie Lee Curtis,
who received a nomination for best supporting
actress for her role in "Everything Everywhere
All At Once." The "Halloween" star took to
Instagram on January 13th, where she wrote,
"F— COVID! Sadly, this head cheerleader
is not going to be at all the weekend
festivities cheering on her friends and
colleagues. [Life’s] on life's terms."
Curtis also shared that, as a
result of the positive test,
she will not be able to attend either the
BAFTA tea party or Critic Choice Awards,
despite being nominated for the latter ceremony.
Not long after, "The Banshees of Inisherin"
stars Colin Farrell and Brendan Gleeson
were also said to have contracted COVID-19,
according to The Hollywood Reporter. The event
saw "Inisherin" as the night's big winner,
with Farrell nabbing a win for best motion
picture actor in a musical or comedy, Martin
McDonagh getting a win for best screenplay,
and the film itself winning best musical or
comedy motion picture. Per The Hollywood Reporter,
the COVID-19 diagnosis also means that
neither actor will be appearing at the
Critics Choice Awards. So what will happen
at upcoming award shows? Likely not much.
The news of actors such as these contracting
COVID-19 following their appearance at the
Golden Globes highlights the reality
that we are still not fully out of the
COVID-19 pandemic. While vaccines and other
medical breakthroughs have helped the world
readjust over the last few years, there are
still times of the year when the danger is
more present. Such was the case for the
Golden Globes. Not long before the event,
LA Public Health issued a recommended 10-day
mask policy as people transition back into work
and school. The Golden Globe ceremony this year,
however, largely seemed to abandon this mindset,
with the only major attendee seen
wearing a mask being Jessica Chastain.
To some, this might cause concerns for the
upcoming 95th Academy Award ceremony. Although
it's more than likely that Curtis, Farrell,
Gleeson, and any other Golden Globe attendees
who contracted COVID-19 will recover by the time
the Oscars ceremony occurs on March 12th, 2023,
should the Academy be too relaxed
with their pandemic protocols,
we could see another string of sick
celebrities follow up the event. Thankfully,
the Academy's safety measures from last
year's event seemed to have worked out,
as no major news came out regarding confirmed
cases. Only time will tell how the results of this
year's Globes will affect safety precautions
at other award shows in the coming months.